alexis poulain bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors après l' attaque terroriste au
commissariat de rambouillet et la mort
tragique de cette policière l exécutif
est il contraint à une réponse forte en
matière sécuritaire oui clairement et
d'ailleurs on a vu tout le week end un
gérald darmanin y gabriela talent à la
manoeuvre
un projet était déjà dans les tuyaux
c'est ça tombe bien il va être présenté
mercredi un projet de deux locaux à de
la lutte contre le terrorisme l'idée est
de renforcer les mesures existantes de
pérenniser à les mesures d'état
d'urgence dans le temps et surtout de
surveiller les individus déjà affiché
mais ce qui est compliqué dans le cadre
de ces attaques terroristes d'un nouveau
genre où les les des jihadistes
étrangers passent à l'acte sans prévenir
on va dire sur se radicalise ans sur les
réseaux sociaux pour certains c'est le
repérage et dans ce pack est justement
arrive toute une série sur les
algorithmes sur la data les données
comment surveiller ses réseaux sociaux
pour prévenir justement ce passage à
l'acte 2 de ces djihadistes d'un nouveau
genre et on attend évidemment ce projet
de loi ça fait beaucoup c'est un
millefeuille sécuritaire qui est en
train de se mettre en place il ya eu la
loi sur le séparatisme qui était en
préparation avant l'attentât qui a coûté
la vie de samuel pâtit le professeur
décapité par un jihadiste étrangers là
aussi tchétchène il y a aussi la loi
sécurité globale qui est là avec la
surveillance généralisée la de tous les
citoyens on va dire donc on voit que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement est mobilisé
sur cette question sécuritaire avec des
lois qui était en préparation et qui
vont sans doute ça allait s'accélérer
dans le calendrier compte tenu de la
grogne à la fois des policiers qui sont
souvent victimes d'attaqués que ce soit
lors d'interventions ou ici clairement
avec cette policière qui a tragiquement
perdu la vie mais aussi avec le procès
de viry-châtillon on a vu que ras-le-bol
claire des syndicats de policiers quant
à leur sécurité en tant que travailleurs
sur le terrain
donc là on va voir quelles sont les les
conclusions mercredi et la suite dans le
projet de loi alors alexis emmanuel
macron n'a pas forcément une très bonne
image 1
un très bon bilan en matière de sécurité
ou de régalien est ce qu'il peut tout
changer à un an de la présidentielle
oui alors clairement c'est la course qui
est lancé pour cet enjeu sécuritaire
parce qu emmanuel macron est conscient
de sa limite et de sa faiblesse
d'où d'ailleurs ces lois qui était en
préparation avant les drames qui les met
en lumière dans la presse nationale
l'idée c'est bien sûr de faire vite en
un an est-ce que ça peut suffire
ça paraît compliqué parce que m la main
qu'on n'a pas une bonne image sur le
principe de la sécurité ou du régalien
ça a été longtemps un sujet qu'il a
évité d'aborder dans la campagne de 2017
puis ensuite une fois au pouvoir quelque
chose avec lequel il n'est pas vraiment
à l'aise il a fallu longtemps pour
kindle mâcon disent que oui il y avait
un lien certes pas ibid en immédiat
entre l'immigration et une certaine
forme de djihadistes djihadisme pardon
mais il est là contrecarrée par sa
majorité divisée sur ce sujet en disant
on ne peut pas dire ça à la fois c'est
faire le jeu de marine le pen et en même
temps il faudrait faire plus de sécurité
il promet plus de bleu c'est gérald
darmanin qui dit plus de dix mille
policiers à la fin du quinquennat
toutes ces lois sécuritaires bien sûr
qu'ils qui s'empilent mais dans les
faits il restera de voir ce qu'il va se
passer et puis l'image elle est ce
qu'elle est emmanuel macron peine à se
positionner en garant de la sécurité en
personne en présidant à qui est
conscient des dérives sécuritaires ou
non et c'est bien ce qui pose problème
parce que la gestion aussi de la crise
des gilets jaunes a montré une partie de
cette gestion par la violence d'état
plutôt que par une sécurité de tous et
on le sent gênée avec cette thématique
et ça pourrait être dangereux pour lui
évidemment en 2022 alors alexis la
question la sécurité est ce qu est l
pourrait être l'enjeu majeur de 2022
oui alors c'est un des enjeux ça l'a
toujours été à l'insécurité revient
systématiquement tel un serpent de mer
en campagne électorale surtout quand
c'est la présidentielle mais on n'est
plus en 2002 avec le thème de la
sécurité qui était arrivé dans la leyre
la dernière ligne droite et qui avait
fait que marine le pen pardon sur marie
le pen s'était retrouvé face à jacques
chirac au second tour on n'est pas non
plus en 2007 au nicolas sarkozy en avait
fait son cheval de bataille parce qu'il
était ministre de l'intérieur donc il
pouvait surfer sur ce bilan et dire
voilà moi je serais le président
de la sécurité de tous les français là
on est en 2021 2022
l'an prochain et les choses ont changé
il y à la crise d'abord sanitaire du coc
vide qui préoccupe tous est là et c'est
une sécurité de la santé une sécurité
sanitaire
et si le bilan des ménages macro est
mauvais alors il pourra toujours courir
après la sécurité au sens large
ce sera un échec et puis il ya aussi le
risque réel de crise économique et
sociale
et là les français vont attendre
beaucoup sur le plan économique est ce
que la relance rendez vous ou pas donc
la sécurité sera un enjeu pour 2022 mais
loin d'être le seul et sans doute pas le
plus important
alors face à l'inquiétude 1 concernant
la capacité de ce gouvernement
les appels à la sédition à la reprise en
main et bien ils se succèdent dernier en
date l'appel des généraux à la retraite
un silence gêné du gouvernement sur cet
appel salué par marine le pen alors
pourquoi oui alors clairement parce que
on voit bien que dans la gestion
justement de cette crise sanitaire on a
l'impression que le gouvernement a
démissionné ou qu'il n'y a plus personne
n'y a plus de pilote dans l'avion - et
donc on a vu des appels à la sédition on
a vu des appels aussi à reprendre les
choses en main dernier en date comme
vous le dites dans valeurs actuelles cet
appel de généraux à la retraite qui
entre les lignes un appel carrément un
putsch en dix ans il ne continue à faire
ce qu'il fait c'est à dire rien ou très
mal il va falloir que l'armée emboîte le
pas et prenne ses responsabilités marine
le pen disant oui il faut bien sûr
remettre ce pays d'aplomb et du côté de
l'elysée du côté du gouvernement il a
fallu attendre 48 heures pour que
florence parly ministre des armées
disent que l'armée n'est pas dans un
rôle politique elle n'a pas être dans un
rôle politique qu'elle est là pour être
la garante de la souveraineté de la
france de la sécurité bien sûr du pays
n'est certainement pas pour jouer un
rôle politique pour tel ou tel parti
ça a été bien long et laborieux
effectivement de se positionner je crois
que c'est dangereux de penser
qu'aujourd'hui des généraux à la
retraite pourrait être une solution ça
on appelle ça un putsch en tout
simplement
en politique classique et mais ce que ça
dit c'est que derrière on voit bien que
le pouvoir des mains de mâcon s'effriter
qu'il a du mal à tenir les troupes que
ce soit les corps intermédiaires armée
police mais aussi l'administration parce
qu'il ya un ras-le bol réel parce
qu'aussi lié à une absence de stratégie
il ya une absence aussi de temps long et
de dire mais qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer on a l'impression de ne pas
sortir depuis un an de cette crise
sanitaire et on a l'impression que tout
est une improvisation permanente ce
n'est pas ça gouverner ce n'est pas ça
et résultat des courses il ya tout le
monde essaye de te dire qu'il faut faire
autre chose faire autrement et avant
2022 or il ya l'échéance 2022 c'est une
échéance électorale dans le cadre
démocratique de la république et c'est
aujourd'hui je crois que tout va jouer
dans ce cadre là et marine le pen a
peut-être été un peu trop ambitieuse ou
trop rapide
adoubé d'un seul coup les généraux qui
souhaitait faire entre guillemets un
coup d'état
merci beaucoup avec 6 l'édito politique
d'alexis poulain c'est tous les lundis
matin dans la matinale de rtl france